nice purple badge and uh we've got my
friend my
my uh black friend here
donnell rawlings giving him a round of
applause everybody
i don't want a round of applause i wanna
i will first of all apologize to all my
fans
[Laughter]
they're they're going to look at this
and say what the [ __ ] is he doing after
yeah
desperate times we require desperate
first of all no no no no no no first of
all we be clear
yeah for everyone let them know that i
don't want to be here okay
let me be clear no no no no yeah because
people like all they
[ __ ] got such a friendship in the
bond i don't want to be here
all right and the only reason i want to
be clear all right the only reasons
and this is a part i don't understand
bobby this podcast has so many fans
exactly thank you look at it like a
person is going on a tv show
he'd know they're going to ask some dumb
questions but there's so many viewers
that you gotta go there right right
product and [ __ ] yeah the only reason
i'm here
is because uh they're people that love
you we're not the kelly clarkson show is
that what you're saying no not
not even okay kelly clark said no but
people go on there because there's got a
lot of viewership and
is that what he's saying yeah that's the
job okay what i'm going to say to you is
this
and if my podcast had more viewers i
would never be on this [ __ ]
i need to the people in the streets told
me all right they said you want to be a
part of that but
facts are facts okay facts are facts all
right and it's so interesting that you
say that because i wasn't even gonna
bring this up
but it's like when you started your new
podcast right
you try to start a little war with me
right on instagram
which to me made it seem like you wanted
to come onto our podcast
and you want to collaborate no i wanted
to [ __ ] with you
yeah oh you wanted to [ __ ] with me yeah
yeah yeah
i wanted to like i like fighting you i
like what he did
yeah i like fighting you i like funny
but i had to stop the fight because
nobody wanted to join the team
you were too deep you know yeah yeah i'm
real dear and then the asian community
when it comes to like
anything to do with uh
like packing or anything like that i'm
gonna
yeah you're gonna lose don't even have
this many viewers
you have one young asian [ __ ]
right
that created some type of robot
that's what you do yeah yeah no i like
[ __ ] yeah but i like [ __ ] with you
too but there is something
with us that whenever i see you
sometimes you'll like walk the other way
or you
you even before the pandemic you would
create a distance
because you you you can't handle my my
sexual energy
okay guess what this is why
you're such a genius because i don't
know how many years that it took you to
figure it out yeah but you're absolutely
right
i can't handle sexual energy from
anybody with a dick
you know what i'm saying like but i i
don't have sexual energy
to you for you i just exude it because
i'm just a being
i know you're a being but i'm not that
type of being right right we're
different type of beings you know what
i'm saying yeah
i know and this i know you're from a
place where like
and this may sound weird for some people
yeah we're kissing the guy in the mouth
is not considered homosexual
it's i i don't i find it european i
don't find it homosexual that's my point
i'm not a european [ __ ] yeah
yeah okay but you do
you do know europe exists i do actually
you told me to european [ __ ] that's
like
oh you like some of my favorite [ __ ]
european but it's not
they're [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah all right
they have vaginas
right i don't think they're not purple
vaginas okay but they have vaginas
all right that's the difference in
cultures oh okay let me just say this
then okay for instance if i was do you
like my hat
it's it's it's it's good i really i
that's my style yeah yeah yeah
i really like nature we'll get to that
later well you could have rocked that
hat you couldn't rock that hat 30 years
ago
i could rock i got swag i can rock
anything no i think 30 years ago would
have been weird now
as you're older you asked me a question
bobby i'm giving my answer
and with that you said no so are you
going to interview me or are you going
to interview yourself
i'm just saying because
don't leave don't leave just leave all
right all right
you need somebody to bounce ideas off
i'm here for you yeah first off i'm
disturbed by this [ __ ] plexiglass
whatever [ __ ] you call it yeah because i
know you're trying to pra pro
practice correct covert protocol but me
being from the hood and you being asian
on the other side of glass
yeah this is where you guys get
empowered
[Laughter]
i'm telling you like in certain
neighborhoods
like the [ __ ] asian person talks more
[ __ ] the thicker the bulletproof glasses
yeah yeah
you know right now you're not going to
talk to my [ __ ] because i could kick
myself through this
you had that [ __ ] [ __ ] right
here you was like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you on
my show